from the post-millennial US military
bases in Iraq Syria targeted in drone
attack injuries reported wait who wants
to read that headline for me one more
time US military bases in Iraq Syria
targeted in drone attack injuries
reported all right now now my question
for you is what stands out in that in
that
headline wait anybody anybody notice
anything interesting about that that
headline Iraq and Syria Isis Syria Syria
US military bases in Syria but why are
we there that's right everybody knows
about Iraq and Afghanistan and
complained about it and somehow we ended
up in Syria and now there's drone
attacks on them apparently the dod
announced that multiple US military
bases in the Middle East have been a
target of drone attacks as a result of
the escalation with the Israel Hamas War
the dod did not reveal the Damage Done
to the bases but confirmed the US
service member sustained minor injuries
from the strike attacks so far drone
attacks have occurred on the US military
bases in Iraq and Syria I love that one
so um yeah we're under
attack I don't like to say that because
I don't like all the foreign
intervention stuff but if us assets
military bases are being
attacked the only thing separating us
from World War II is the moment when our
politicians decide to say the words
because if we we we're deploying our
troops into the into the region around
uh in the Mediterranean around Israel if
we've got everything we got troops
deployed to Europe we're involved in
Ukraine and our bases are being attacked
as soon as our politicians are like can
we say it now okay we'll say it now like
there you go but it's it's just so
hypocritical or ironic because I'm not
saying that we shouldn't defend our
bases or property that's not what I'm
getting out with this but here we are
potentially going to defend our bases in
another foreign country but we won't
even defend our border we won't defend
when they're cutting through the bars at
the southern border but that is not
defend Patrol is cutting through the
barb wire I watched it happen I watched
probably 400 people crossing minutes
Texas puts up the barb wire and then
federal agents cut cut it Texas Nation
Su to get the buoys out of there MH yeah
because they said it wasn't humanitarian
at first and then they changed their
mind and said you need Congressional
approval well so the reason they're
cutting the Barb wires just to make it
more humanitarian because as soon as
they step foot on us soil which is right
across the barb wire they have to let
them in and quote unquote give them a
shot they don't have to they they're
like who the law requires it okay dude
well they make up these things like what
was it with one of the Bridges I think
near not Eagle Pass but they were saying
oh well it's dangerous this this is a
steep embankment so people could fall
but they shouldn't be attempting to
cross the border in the first place so
why are we making accommodations to make
it safer AK easier to cross the border
well and they know this all the migrants
crossing they're fully aware of this too
because when you when you speak to them
they'll tell you you know we came here
because we were told we would get a
better way of life and we could come to
this area we could come to Eagle Pass so
migrants all across the world most of
them aren't coming from Mexico they're
coming from all over MH yeah I mean it's
I mean the largest number right now from
what I've seen from border patrol is
Venezuelans which you know you could
understand why maybe they're fleeing
their country on the other hand should
we just be like it's no problem come on
in the other question is how are they
getting here from Venezuela these people
are paid $25 a month who is funding them
to come from Venezuela and get all the
way to our Southern border that's the
real question what NOS are involved what
governments are assisting in this people
are getting on cargo trains come
right up to our Southern border and we
have no leadership there I don't know I
don't know if this is part of the same
report but I'm seeing on Twitter that
Rockets have hit military bases in uh uh
at near Baghdad International Airport MH
of course they didn't when you look at
the rhetoric and the discourse outside
of the of America everyone is saying
this is the responsibility of Israel and
America this is the responsibility of
Ukraine and America it's all America is
intertwined with all of these feuds of
course someone's going to do something
eventually yeah well well to Scott's
point if you lived in a dangerous
neighborhood you would lock your door
right if we know we're on the brink of
global crisis you know obviously I think
we should have secured the Border a
really long time ago this is basic in
101 how to maintain your country right
but they didn't and now that we are on
the brink of War on several fronts why
are we not number one securing our own
border why was that not part of why did
Joe Biden not mention that during his
speech why is it about what's happening
somewhere else when he's not ensuring
that the people here are safe first it's
not you can't have compassion for loss
of life anywhere else it's not that you
can you know we can debate whe what what
involvement we should have but
ultimately the first thing he should do
is say we are making sure the border is
secure you have more and more people
every day who hate America because of
how involved we are everywhere else and
we have our fingers and every pie and we
have record border crossings we have
estimated
27,000 migrants encounters well just
last month that's in September in a
month one month that's record-breaking
and that's just the ones we know about
yep true that are processed and I know
this isn't just going to the rabbit hole
of a border discussion but really we
need to do a better job of messaging the
America first message when it especially
comes to the Border what don't Democrats
want Democrats want to reduce gun
violence right guns are trafficked in
and out of the United States because of
the open border they care about women
right and they want to stop sexual
assaults right and they want to stop
human trafficking right then what about
closing the border to make sure that
women and children are protected but
this is this is consistent with
Democratic logic right like if they
really believe that we should protect
children and we should uh prevent child
labor they would demand all the
manufacturing jobs come back from China
right they would put it in a country
that is actually regulating these things
but instead they are able to turn a
blind eye because it's not really about
and I don't want to generalize here
there are obviously people who vote
Democrat who really do call for and
believe in these things but they are
being misled by anyone who has any kind
of control over that party because
ultimately the values that they preach
are not anything that they actually make
decisions based on well and and why are
some deaths more important than others
nobody talks about the 300 people that
are dying daily from fenol you know
they'll they'll talk about one death
they'll talk about the atrocity that is
happening that is awful but what about
fentol the drugs that crisis as well
they're just so many things that
honestly if we just funded and secured
the Border we could cease so many
problems uh here domestically but also
internationally do you feel like people
respond to this type of messaging when
you are talking to people on the ground
because you do so much on the ground
work oh absolutely I'm telling you right
now the America first message is
resonating when I say why are we sending
billions to Ukraine to secure their
border while our border is wide open
that makes the light bulb go on and they
go you're right and I go wait we we uh
want to save democracy overseas right
and we want to make sure that they uh
are prosperous then why are our roads
crumbling our bridges crumbling our
education system crumbling our cities
look at Detroit look at I mean you want
to talk a wasteland go walk through San
Francisco California go to Los Angeles
California been there done that yeah but
people seem to think if we vote another
Democrat in in these cities that it will
I mean this is what happened in Chicago
right Chicago's crime went up they voted
a more intense leftist in I don't
understand I mean it's it's very hard
for me to reconcile with other than the
fact that maybe they're just really
rooting for their team right they think
well if we just give someone with more
radical Solutions a shot things will get
better it doesn't seem like it occurs to
them that the path they're walking down
is is is wrong well I think there is a
realignment going on I know I don't know
if we wanted to go straight into
politics but I will tell you we just had
a gubernatorial election on Saturday
October 14th in Louisiana and an
important statistic for you guys is 12%
of the black community voted for
Republican Jeff Landry for governor and
furthermore there's a place called
shreport you got New Orleans you got
Baton Rouge you got shreport those are
like the top Democratic uh majority
minority areas well actually cat Parish
voted for Jeff Landry and recently they
just elected a Republican mayor what's
the shift what what was the percentage
of black voters for Republicans previous
to this well let's put it this way they
didn't have for the last 20 years a
republican may had always been
Democratic it just changed over in
shareport and and John Bell Edwards was
the only Democratic governor in the Deep
South basically correct so now Louisiana
which votes red as far as I know it's
gone for Trump every year it is now
dominated by a complete Republican
majority I mean they have control of the
house and of the governorship from what
I know about it you're probably much
more informed correct the last is now
Kentucky they have a Democrat but the
fact of the matter is we have to bring
this America First Mantra this message
to communities everywhere and we're
seeing a shift happening but it's going
to be us going into those communities
talking about these issues like the
Border like for example Pennsylvania
that's not a border state they recently
had an illegal immigrant that escaped
from jail who was in jail because he had
killed his lover that was on the loose
for 2 weeks in southeast Pennsylvania
this isn't something that just affects
California and Nevada and Arizona and
Texas this is a problem that affects all
states oh go ahead you go no you I'm
here all the time you go you have to
give them a reason to care though and I
think that's been such a great failing
of the RNC and nrcc for not paying for
ads to make the issue of the border and
make the issue of immigration too big to
ignore so that you can have that
national America First messaging
everywhere because in certain areas like
you know unless they hear the message
unless you give them a reason to care
that messaging won't work in a lot of
local areas unless you bring it to them
well and furthermore one more point and
I I'm belaboring this but this is like
my number one issue of why I do what I
do look at New York with the migrant
crisis that's happening right now
American citizens veterans that have
served our country that are giving us
this opportunity to have this free
speech right now are being pushed out
for legal immigrants and I want to be on
the record and say this loudly and
clearly that Democrats choose illegal
immigrants over black white and brown
American citizens and that is the
message that we also need to nationalize
that in uh on Long Island in Manhattan
uh everywhere across the country Look at
California Mett where they're going to
give College tuition to illegal aliens
and not American citizens okay yeah can
we say shout out to Texas though because
this would not be happening that that
conversation would not be happening in
New York where I live unless they
started busting those migrants saying
you know what you want to take them then
take and several other states too have
have started joining in I can't remember
which Arizona does it um I mean
obviously we had Florida with uh marth's
Vineyard the the thing is though the
majority of the I mean the number of
migrants that those states have bust
does not compare to your point earlier
migrants know that they can get to New
York and have a right to shelter and be
accommodated the number of people that
have been busted by Texas makes up a
percentage but it does not account for
the overwhelming majority of illegal
governs have arrived in New York and
it's not just New York City it's New
York State thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net